3 23 les liens les bacs de profession
aviez par carey et je sais pas car veche
pied du type cw de loi qui roule temps
ferrari à la plage comme à la ville qui
vont chez cartier comme ils vont chez
fauchon psyché nous tirer de l'oubli de
b2b whaou
croyez vous que je sois jaloux chiboub
pas du tout chip pas du tout mais moi
j'ai un piège à filles à kege tabou un
jour jouer xsara qui fait crac boum hue
eu les filles tombent à mes jours oui
les filles en temps en temps bas mais je
pars oui j'ai pas peur des teams in et
qui mange avons au drugstore miam miam
miam miam
nania bien ou qui travaillent tout comme
les casseurs ni avec la main ni avec
leurs pieds gna gna gna gna gna gna gna
quand et où que je sois jallieu chine
pas du tout chibout pas du tout moi j'ai
un piège à filles un piège tabou un
joujou extra qui fait crac boum hue les
filles en temps mais je me méfie en
tombent en temps va mais je ne me suis
pas je ne crois pas des qu'aux les super
morts les bébés au carrure d'athlète y
ont recours aux yeux d'acier au regard
toqué en harley davidson il se promène
si angie ou croyez-vous que je sois
jaloux chip pas du tout chip pas du tout
moi j'ai un piège à filles
un piège tabou un joujou avec ça qui
fait crac boum hue répit encore à mes
genoux les filles entendent ans tombe à
mes jeux wii est grevé les fous du zen
ce qu'ils disent et ce qu'ils savent
parler bla bla bla bla comme m6 boom par
leo mccarey chez catherine heures ce qui
se maria madeleine bla bla bla bla
belgique
boum croyez vous que je sois jaloux chic
pas du tout scheer pas du tout a pour
moi j'ai un piège à filles à viège
tavola joujou extra qui fait crac boum
hue et pillant thomas mais joue les
filles entendent les filles entend damer
je me méfie entendent les filles ans
toman genoux des filles entendre autant
ma maison par louise voilà les
palétuviers